[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voici le temps des discours officiels le
temps des promesses
en fait le temps des mensonges
ecoutez-le et tous ceux qui vont prendre
la parole après moi ils vont vous
promettre monts et merveilles ils vont
vous dire que le chômage recule que
l'emploi progresse ce sont des menteurs
vous travailleurs vous le savez dans les
entreprises et malheureusement les plans
de licenciements et de restructuration
s'accélère et comment se fait-il que
depuis cinq ans où la gauche plurielle
est au pouvoir il n'y a pas eu un seul
député pour déposer un seul texte qui
interdisent par la loi un seul
licenciement
pourtant les travailleurs de toutes les
entreprises sont allés voir les députés
les ministres
et qu'est-ce qu'ils ont répondu ils ont
dit juridiquement ne peut pas interdire
les licenciements par la loi c'est un
mensonge pur et simple
quand il s'agit de voter des lois contre
les travailleurs les députés savent
parfaitement le faire il n'aurait pas le
pouvoir de voter une seule loi défense
des travailleurs contre les
licenciements
en réalité le problème n'est pas
juridique il est politique
ils ont accepté de capituler devant
l'europe de maastricht
ils ont accepté d'été simple instrument
des patrons et de l'europe de maastricht
alors le problème est clairement posée
j'espère déclaré l'ouverture de la
campagne
les patrons n'ont pas eu à se plaindre
du gouvernement de la gauche plurielle
c'est vrai les travailleurs en revanche
sont indignés et quand ils entendent
chirac et jospin promet encore plus de
licenciements après l'élection
ils sont encore plus indigné oui le
combat à l'ordre du jour c'est l'unité
pour interdire les licenciements
l'unité pour rompre avec le diktat de
l'europe de maastricht
[Musique]